we have full on Panic at The Biden White
House tonight Joe Biden is now facing
what a very serious impeachment inquiry
over an extensive multi-million dollar
what I'm calling the Joe Biden bribery
money laundering corruption scheme
allegations it involves Joe it involves
a zero experienced son Hunter and other
members of the Biden family Syndicate or
if you're in Fulton County Georgia that
would be called an Enterprise they like
that word down there anyway these are
legitimate allegations backed up with a
mountain of very real evidence and while
everyone is innocent until proven guilty
uh there is no doubt that Joe Biden
participated in Hunter Shady Farm
business deals we're talking about tens
of millions of dollars and Joe Biden did
it as vice president and according to
the White House spokesman Chief
propaganda for the moment some guy by
the name of Ian Sams Ian is obsessed
with the show he often responds to
what's said on this show this is only a
story about a Father's Love For His Son
watch
one of the other allegations is the
president was present at some of the
meetings between Hunter Biden and his
business associates uh why was the
president at those meetings on those
phone calls
well again I think this is part of the
right Wing's misinformation machine to
try to confuse people uh about what the
truth is the truth is that the president
as he has said publicly for years uh
calls his family every day to check in
he calls his son every day to check in
he calls his other family members to
check in to see how they're doing he
loves them there's they're a tight-knit
family now that's what a loving father
does right he sends his struggling drug
addicted son all over the world
including two countries that are top
geopolitical foes to do deals with
sketchy corrupt oligarchs while helping
facilitate those deals with phone calls
meetings and dinners and by the way did
I tell you his son has no experience
nothing really to offer these countries
anyway then based on Hunter Biden's tax
well he complained bitterly that pops
that would be President Joe Biden then
Vice President Joe Biden was taking half
of his income of just the classic
father-son love story right well now the
White House is demanding that media
Outlets tout this absurd Narrative of
theirs and trashed the gop's new
impeachment inquiry now this is Joe's PR
room now let's see how many dupes in the
media are going to regurgitate this
nonsense in a very dishonest letter for
example uh propagandist Ian Sam's writes
quote there is simply no evidence at all
that Joe Biden did anything wrong much
less impeachable now naturally some on
fake news CNN they were all but eager to
tow the party line let's take a quick
look have literally been looking for
evidence of this for years and have not
yet found any this house speaker is now
green lighting an investigation into
Biden without any evidence of wrongdoing
I'm going to reiterate to the audience
because we need to be clear there is not
evidence well they don't have evidence
yet to prove that very serious
allegations again uh no evidence that we
have seen as for evidence though there
hasn't been any House Republicans have
still not delivered any proof of
President Biden directly benefiting from
his son's business dealings
all right now despite the sick offense
over at fake news CNN there is trouble
in Paradise for Biden's re-election
campaign many in the media mob they are
now beginning to turn on Joe Biden this
is getting interesting here's a brand
new op-ed from one of Biden's favorite
columnists at the Washington Post the
very liberal David Ignatius it's
entitled President Biden should not run
again in 2024 and according to Ignatius
Biden's age has been the subject of
dinner table conversations Across
America this summer no since he started
running if you were watching this show
Mr Ignatius clearly you need to expand
your your news-based knowledge base
where you get your news from anyway
Ignatius continues quote because of
their concerns about Biden's age voters
would sensibly focus on his presumptive
running mate that would be Kamala Harris
he's less popular than Biden and while
Politico calls for Harris to be replaced
as Biden's running mate Ignatius
Ignatius doesn't want either Joe or
Kamala on the ticket he also takes a
shot at Hunter's Farm business deals it
is a devastating rebuke of Biden's
re-election chances and by the way this
is now only the latest Domino to fall in
a series of major influential left-wing
media figures now turning on President
Biden I talked about the canary in the
coal mine that was probably maureened
out at the New York Times her column
blasting Biden's unconscionable and
Despicable treatment of his seventh
grandchild four years old that he
wouldn't even acknowledge existed but in
the last week alone now the pressure is
really ramping up CNN's van Jones quote
would you give this Grandpa a
high-stress job for six more years
I'll ask this question could Joe Biden
even be a competent Walmart greeter I I
don't know
that was funny come on meanwhile Obama's
former Chief political strategist David
Axelrod by the way this is a pretty
influential guy within Democratic party
ranks he was the architect behind Barack
Obama's success he said Biden needs to
decide if he can complete the job or
step aside the Raging Cajun when you
lose James Carville you're in deep Adam
Schiff if you know what I mean but he
said that Biden has a clear age problem
and called his plummeting poll numbers
quote troubling over the weekend even
over at msdnc Chuck Todd was all begging
California governor Gavin Newsom to
enter this race and even get this even
morning liberal Joe this is what he had
to say today about Biden and by the way
what he's saying is a thousand percent
true but once he got something right
take a look
Mika and I uh everybody we talked to
every political discussion all uh it
talks a lot about Trump but when it
comes to Joe Biden people say man he's
too old to run isn't he I mean he's not
gonna he's not really gonna every disc
when I say every discussion I don't mean
99 of the discussion every discussion we
got it I asked Reverend Al and he was
hearing it all the time on our show this
past week he's hearing it as well so you
know we often will complain about
Republicans who will say one thing about
Donald Trump off the air and another on
air well let me just say Democrats off
the air will say Joe Biden's too old why
is he running
on the air they won't say that
now when you're a Democrat and you even
lose Morning Joe and you lose David
Axelrod and Van Jones and James Carville
and David Ignatius and Maureen down you
probably need to watch out now some in
the White House Press Corps they're even
now beginning to ask questions about
Biden's constant lying maybe they
learned a thing or two as they watch
this show every night by the way we're
glad you're watching take a look
in the past couple weeks the president
has lied about being at Ground Zero the
day after the September 11th attacks
falsely claimed you saw the Pittsburgh
bridge collapse I claimed his
grandfather died in the hospital days
before his birth what is going on with
the president is he just believing
things that didn't happen did happen or
is he just read what making stuff up
the president was
deeply touched and honored to be able to
spend 9 11 with military members there
in Alaska and some families and he spoke
about a visit to Ground Zero which he
did participate in about a week or so
after uh the the event and what that
looked and what that smelled and what
like that felt like and it had a
visceral impact on him as it did so many
other Americans on that terrible day
the question was why does he lie so much
uh that wasn't the question he answered
is there anyone at this White House
willing to give an honest forthcoming
answer apparently not but the next
couple of weeks will be very telling if
any prominent elected Democrats join
their friends in the mob in the media
and call for Joe Biden a step aside his
re-election bid it is done it is over no
one in the in the Democratic party or
the media protect Biden because they
think he is a good president or even a
decent person they just want to beat who
they think the Republican nominee is
going to be Donald Trump and if Joe
can't do the job they're going to send
him packing wait for that first
prominent elected official and tonight
more bad news for Biden new evidence
from John Solomon that Biden held a
private meeting as vice president at the
Naval Observatory with Hunter Biden's
business partners apparently they were
discussing barisma and a possible
candidate for U.N secretary gen General
now why would a vice president discuss
these topics with his son's business
partners and there were all the other
trips to the Obama White House and all
the other trips meeting and dinners and
lunches and everything in between with
Hunter's business partners and then of
course oligarchs even from Russia now
according to Joe in a newly surfaced
video from 2019 he was just never warned
of any potential conflict of interest
nobody told him when pressed by an MPR
reporter he seems to blame his dying son
Beau Biden see if this makes sense to
you
you know it didn't look good for Hunter
Biden to be on that board even if he did
nothing wrong the Optics weren't good
and you talk a lot about what it means
to be a Biden and the Integrity that is
imbued in that family name but there
were former White House aides of yours
who tried to warn you about the
potential conflicts of interest nobody
warned me about a potential conflict of
interest nobody warned me about that and
at the same time George Kent the state
department official testified that he
raised it to you
never heard that once to your stuff and
your staff told him he has no bandwidth
well myself I guess that's why he said
it because my son was on his deathbed
what hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else